vous avez forcément déjà plus ses
petites billes blanches quand j'étais
petit j'adorais en prendre sans me
rendre compte que c'était un médicament
ces pilules consommée par plus de 50 %
des français sont ce qu'on appelle de
l'homéopathie
mais est ce que vous saviez que même si
elle était vendue en pharmacie et
qu'elles étaient prescrites par les
médecins pas tout le monde ne les
considère pas comme des médicaments que
ce serait une forme de médecine
ethiquement très critiquable je vous
propose d'étudier ça ensemble comment
marche le nommer au pâtis retourne au
xviiie siècle
cette merveilleuse époque où la médecine
s'étaient un peu du grand n'importe quoi
c'était le bon vieux temps où quand des
malades ouvrez les veines
ça s'appelait une saignée c'était 107
aider à aller mieux
c'est dans ce contexte qu'en 1796 samuel
hahnemann un médecin allemand reprend
les bases de la médecine d'hippocrate
selon lui il faut soigner le mal par le
mal
c'est ça l'homéopathie et c'est en
opposition complète avec la médecine
classique pour des maux de tête par
exemple en médecine classique on va
utiliser un anti-inflammatoire pour
t'aider à calmer la douleur alors qu en
homéopathie
on utilisera une substance qui causent
le mal de tête
celle ci est censé en théorie aider le
système immunitaire à le combattre et
ainsi aider le patient à guérir plus
vite
contrairement ce que tout le monde pense
l'homéopathie ce n'est pas que des
plantes c'est aussi des ingrédients
d'origine animale est autre qu un peu
plus bizarres ou par exemple mais
fictive plutôt rieuse qui est en fait
des glandes anales de putois ou encore
medori nomme à base d'un lisa de
sécrétions sûrs et ralp eurent eu
l'envié n'aura gic d'un malade qui n'a
pas encore été soigné autrement dit du
pénis surtout que je vous apprends rien
en vous disant qu'un malaise des
substances nocives c'est pas sans risque
c'est pour ça que samuel hahnemann à une
idée fabuleuse et si ces substances
on les dit lui en soit c'est pas bête en
diminuant beaucoup les molécules actives
on enlève la toxicité et les effets
secondaires
mais comment ça marche la dilution en
homéopathie sur les flacons on retrouve
des nombreux suivis de la mention ch ou
cas c'est le niveau de dilution de ce
qu'on appelle la teinture mère la base
du médicament l'homéopathie c'est comme
le sirop de grenadine
sauf que c'est beaucoup
plus dilué pour faire un médicament
homéopathique c'est rsa on prend une
goutte de la teinture mère
disons ici une goutte de plus de pénis
on la mélange avec 90 gouttes tôt ou
d'alcool on va ensuite dynamiser la
solution alors le mot il a l'air cool
mais ça veut juste dire qu'on va secouer
le flacon et une fois que c'est fait on
obtient une dilution 1 ch
techniquement la quantité de molécules
actives et divisé par 100 on répète
ensuite l'opération on prend une goutte
de cette solution on la remet dans 99
goutte d'eau ont redynamisé et voilà on
a 2 ch vous faites ça une trentaine de
fois mais on ploie le gifle sur 1000
dilution dessus vous voulez on prend une
goutte de cette solution ultra diluée et
on la met sur de petites billes de sucre
voilà tu l'as tu habilles homéopathiques
voyez ce tableau c'est le nombre moyen
de molécules dans ta bille à 12 c à
chili a autant de molécules de plus de
pénis que dans tous les océans de la
planète au dessus de 12 dilution il y a
statistiquement plus aucune chance qu'il
y ait une seule molécule active dans le
médicament est à 44 cela représenterait
la dilution d'un atome de plus de pénis
dans tout l'univers observable
vous avez bien compris ta bille c'est du
sucre à 100% mais avant de vous
expliquer la thèse derrière l'efficacité
de l'homéopathie
connaissez-vous l'oscillococcinum et si
vous connaissez ces pubs que vous voyez
à la télé est à grippaux aussi que vos
silences médicaments censés traiter les
états grippaux pour faire la teinture
mère de l'oscillococcinum on utilise en
fait du foie et du coeur de canard qu'on
fait macérer pendant 40 jours
oui c'est du jus de canard pétrifiée
mais pour faire jouer on appelle ça un
auto lisa mais pourquoi on fait ça en
1920 joseph roye homéopathe français
découvrent une bactérie mutante le silo
coke c'est elle qui serait à l'origine
de nombreuses maladies notamment la
grippe
on dirait à la great justement il décida
de faire un remède homéopathique en
implantant ces bactéries dans le foie et
le coeur de canard en diluant les
particules de foi et de coeur il
concocte à un remède magique qui
soi-disant des résultats miraculeux
sauf que voilà aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait
c'est que ce micro-organisme n'existe
pas et que la grippe n'est pas une
bactérie mais plusieurs types de virus à
30 euros la boîte ça fait cher payé les
billes sucrée à base de bactéries
imaginaire on comprend pourquoi en mars
boiron a déboursé 12 millions de dollars
pour faire taire l'action de groupes de
consommateurs américains qui dénoncé
l'inefficacité et la pub mensongère de
l'oscillococcinum ça n'a pas marché
puisque boiron a quand même fait plus de
600 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2018 soit 50 millions de
plus qu'en 2012
et là vous vous dites sûrement ouais
c'est quoi ça et vous avez raison
comment un médicament comme celui ci a
pu être mise en vente et dans 100% des
pharmacies en fait contrairement aux
médicaments classiques les médicaments
homéopathiques ne sont pas tenus de
prouver leur efficacité
seulement de prouver qu'il ne provoque
aucun effet secondaire
en gros la seule chose que vous pouvez
être sûr en prenant de l'homéopathie
c'est que ça vous rendra pas plus
malades
comment justifier que ces billets le
moindre effet bah oui parce qu'à une
théorie derrière ça en 1988 un
chercheurs publient une thèse dans le
magazine nature nature c'est pas
n'importe quoi tout est censé prouver
que l'homéopathie peut fonctionner
c'est la mémoire de l'eau les chaînes de
télévision s'affolent c'était enfin la
preuve qu'on attendait pour prouver que
l'homéopathie marche
selon le chercheur l'eau garderai en
mémoire les propriétés
électromagnétiques des substances avec
lesquels elle a été diluée et dynamiser
cette théorie permettrait d'expliquer
pourquoi malgré de très forte dilution
les médicaments homéopathiques garde des
effets thérapeutiques pour résumer très
grossièrement la thèse on met de l'adn
dans un verre d'eau on enregistre les
fréquences émises et au fait écouter ces
fréquences à un autre verre d'eau si on
donne la deuxième vers toutes les
protéines nécessaires et bien l'eau
serait capable de reconstituer l'adn du
verre précédent justo en écoutant les
fréquences comme si l'eau pouvait
enregistrer des informations du plu de
pénis pour les restituer dans la capture
de sucre et je vais pas vous mentir
qu'on écoute des vidéos dédiées
ça a l'air crédible il y a tout des
notions compliqué de la physique
quantique et surtout un peu de magie qui
al'air scientifique
de quoi titiller l'imagination mais il
ya un problème
aucune étude sérieuse n'a réussi à
trouver des résultats similaires en
sciences on doit pouvoir prouver que ces
résultats sont réplicable sinon ça n'a
aucune valeur et on comprend bien
pourquoi je vous rappelle que l'eau du
robinet c'est de l'eau qui a été filtrée
dans des centres d'épuration macérant
des jours entiers dans la merde de
millions de français et six lois une
mémoire elle doit être traumatisé et
vous la buvée tous les jours qu'on peut
trouver beaucoup d'études portant sur
l'efficacité de l'homéopathie toutes les
étudier demanderait un travail
gigantesque
mais ce n'est pas le genre de choses qui
freine les scientifiques
1015 la n a jamais recèle agence de
sûreté australienne a synthétisé les
résultats de 176 étude basée sur
l'efficacité de l'homéopathie leurs
résultats il n'y a aucune preuve que
l'homéopathie et efficace et pire
choisir l'homéopathie à la place d'un
traitement qui a fait ses preuves c'est
mettre sa santé en danger
pourtant certaines études montrent que
l'homéopathie et efficace est-ce que la
nhk mersey ne les a pas étudié et bien
si mais ces études étaient soit de
mauvaise qualité soit sur un nombre de
patients trop faible pour être crédible
en gros meilleur et l'étude plus elle
prouve la non efficacité de
l'homéopathie et le nhk mersey n'est pas
le seul organisme à avoir fait ce genre
d'étude
cependant ils arrivent tous à la même
conclusion mais certains vont me dire
mais moi l'homéopathie j'en ai pris
plein de fois et ça a fonctionné
et vous avez raison l'homéopathie d'une
certaine façon ça marche
et là dans les commentaires déferlement
de rageux je vous explique
l'homéopathie c'est comme un bisou
magique de votre maman sur une blessure
techniquement c'est encore ouvert ça
pisse le sang mais vous savez mon mal
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet placebo
ça vous est jamais arrivé de ne plus
avoir mal à la tête juste après avoir
pris un doliprane pourtant est ce que
vous saviez que le doliprane il faut au
moins 15 minutes pour commencer à agir
même les médicaments efficaces profite
de l'effet placebo et c'est pour ça que
votre médecin continue à vous prescrire
de l'homéopathie une surdose de
doliprane
ça peut être mortel sur deux dômes pâtit
ça n'existe pas si vous continuez à
avoir mal à la tête
vingt minutes après avoir pris votre
doliprane augmenter la dose ça serait
dangereux pour vous mieux vaut que vous
preniez plus de ces petites capsules en
espérant guérir avec ça eh oui
l'homéopathie sauve des vies
partout dans le monde on se méfie de
plus en plus de la médecine on se tourne
de plus en plus vers des médecines
alternatives des alternatives parfois
dangereuses qui vous font vous tourner
vers des plantes ou les surdosages sont
potentiellement mortelle
son plus bas bouche ça partance et les
sorties monsieur si vous vous tourner
vers le haut pâti au moins on eu sur
rien de mal va vous arriver
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter avec des
pharmaciens est pharmacienne qui vendait
de l'homéopathie et même eux sont
d'accord sur le fait qu'il n'y ait
aucune preuve de leur efficacité
mais refuser d'en vente serait un énorme
manque à gagner et puis avec deux jours
de formation pour devenir médecin
homéopathe pourquoi s'en priver c'est
donc un business qui fait vivre beaucoup
de monde notamment les pharmaciens et
les labos de recherche
oui jusqu'ici la sécurité sociale
financé la recherche en remboursant
c'est big de sucre ceci dit tout ça
touche à sa fin car la france décide
d'arrêter le remboursement à partir de
2021 alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de
tout ça prochaine fois que votre grand
mère vous dira de procès granules
magique pensé à lui montrer la vidéo
cette chaîne est là pour ça vous
apprendre des trucs en des bunkers des
petites choses de votre quotidien
du coup pensez à vous abonner on vient
de créer la chaîne c'est important pour
nous symboliquement il s'écoule pour
vous car comme ça toutes les semaines
vous pourrez retrouver une nouvelle
vidéo
c'était ma tartine et oxis merci à tous
les monteurs et tous les rédacteurs à
les amis
[Musique]